okay welcome everybody uh to today's
structure meeting yeah
um and later or following out the
well-being committee meeting as well I'm
going to open the meeting and uh there
are no apologies
um so was that could I just make a note
here at this point for the minutes is
that I had sent an apology for the June
6th meeting of infrastructural services
because I was away on Council business
and missed the opportunity during full
Council for that to be recorded So if
nalavika could just make a note in for
the minutes to be erupted we can do that
sorry about that
okay so I'm going to adjourn the meeting
so that Darren can now start the
well-being meeting and the reason for it
really is to give the youth Council
um some time to do their presentation
and not have to
uh um white during a couple of meetings
with so
a new council is here
tomato cheek